[Music]
did you know that every time musicians
pick up their instruments there are
fireworks going off all over their brain
on the outside they may look calm and
focused reading the music and making the
precise and practice movements required
but inside their brains there's a party
going on how do we know this well in the
last few decades
neuroscientists have made enormous
breakthroughs in understanding how our
brains work by monitoring them in real
time with instruments like fMRI and Pt
scanners when people are hooked up to
these machines tasks such as reading or
doing math problems each have
corresponding areas of the brain where
activity can be observed but when
researchers got the participants to
listen to music they saw fireworks
multiple areas of their brains were
lighting up at once as they process the
sound took it apart to understand
elements like melody and rhythm and then
put it all back together into unified
musical experience and our brains do all
this work in the split second between
when we first hear the music and when
our foot starts to tap along but when
scientists turn from observing the
brains of music listeners to those of
musicians the little backyard fireworks
became a jubilee it turns out that while
listening to music engages the brain in
some pretty interesting activities
playing music is the brain's equivalent
of a full-body workout the
neuroscientist saw multiple areas of the
brain light up simultaneously processing
different information in intricate
interrelated and astonishingly fast
sequences but what is it about making
music that sets the brain alight the
research is still fairly new but
neuroscientists have a pretty good idea
playing a musical instrument engages
practically every area of the brain at
once especially the visual auditory and
motor cortices and as with any other
workout disciplined structured practice
in playing music strengthens those brain
functions allowing us to apply that
strength to other activities the most
obvious difference between listening to
music and playing it is that the latter
requires fine motor skills which are
controlled in both hemispheres of the
brain
it also combines the linguistic and
mathematical precision in which the
left hemisphere is more involved with
the novel and creative content that the
right excels in for these reasons
playing music has been found to increase
the volume and activity in the brain's
corpus callosum the bridge between the
two hemispheres allowing messages to get
across the brain faster and through more
diverse routes this may allow musicians
to solve problems more effectively and
creatively in both academic and social
settings because making music also
involves crafting and understanding its
emotional content and message musicians
often have higher levels of executive
function a category of interlinked tasks
that includes planning strategizing and
attention to detail and requires
simultaneous analysis of both cognitive
and emotional aspects this ability also
has an impact on how our memory systems
work and indeed musicians exhibit
enhanced memory functions creating
storing and retrieving memories more
quickly and efficiently studies have
found that musicians appear to use their
highly connected brains to give each
memory multiple tags such as a
conceptual tag and emotional tag an
audio tag and a contextual tag like a
good internet search engine so how do we
know that all these benefits are unique
to music as opposed to say sports or
painting or could it be that people who
go into music were already smarter to
begin with neuroscientists have explored
these issues but so far they have found
that the artistic and aesthetic aspects
of learning to play a musical instrument
are different from any other activity
studied including other arts and several
randomized studies of participants who
show the same levels of cognitive
function and neural processing at the
start found that those who were exposed
to a period of music learning showed
enhancement in multiple brain areas
compared to the others this recent
research about the mental benefits of
playing music has advanced our
understanding of mental function
revealing the inner rhythms and complex
interplay that make up the amazing
orchestra of our brain
[Music]